hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play fact can
s I am not pronouncing that correctly
but I'm already committed I'm not gonna
change how I talk
okay so we got as an assortment of keys
here especially new is a key to the East
Wing well this is strange for an
abandoned place why would they have
bread freshly baking it oh that's quite
moldy nevermind and this pig is very
spoiled this bone looks stripped yeah
nothing looks good here hello I still
don't have a lantern why was this
important there is so dark here I need
to find a light source before continuing
mmm
I agree I need to find a light source it
is dark so this looks like a throne why
would a hotel need like this I mean I
know they probably need to feed their
patrons but still I have thrown that
doesn't make any sense okay did I go in
there I believe I did that was the
library so let's check the upstairs
rooms actually before I do that there
was a door behind here ah the servants
quarters let's go in here maybe there
will be a lantern in here this console
is supposed to be abandoned
I'm just simple Hungarian farmer shocked
Oh I do not know hello
excuse me oh this is weird ah - monster
he's outside no it doesn't bother for me
hey buddy how you doing hi oh no no get
it out of here
that's right eff off I see you I still
see you I try get out of here okay sell
this pile of bones okay why does he
sound like he's speaking through a tin
can and a string okay I'm finding a lot
of keys huh tell you what
tons of keys everywhere don't know why
so many I guess it is a big hotel you
need to keep it locked up tight for
security reasons for some stupid thing I
guess still no lantern but I now have
the study room key I'm not missing
anything am i fly Oh once again like the
music so anyway things are probably
about to start getting a little freaky
servants of this castle lived here all
in one room
I must have been cramped and annoying
okay now we continue upstairs okay I
thought something was gonna happen the
music just suddenly cut out oh okay what
we got here
West Wing I do not have the West Wing
key music make up your damn mind
ha I'm sorry I didn't mean to break your
[ __ ] it's a hotel
I still hear those whispers seriously
what's with the whispers really freaky
man
really freaky okay so let's go into the
East Wing yes have a swing key hopefully
I can find a light source ah well this
is lovely but very quiet why why is this
so lit no one's supposed to be here
you're not supposed to be here tommye
it's really quiet it's like I hate it
when it's this quiet man oh that's a
clock okay
okay
nothing yet still nothing
I'm guessing almost all of these rooms
are gonna be empty let's see 1 2 3 1 2 1
okay these are the room numbers okay so
this is where the different people lived
if I paid more attention to that note I
could probably pull it up but I don't
see why I would need to Lantern Lantern
need Lantern jeez it's very eerie here
is a good way to describe it that one
was very slow in comparison to the other
ones perhaps I should be concerned
what's this it's a shirt
I thought that was something important
trying to stay observant and relevant to
things here but there doesn't seem to
actually be anything nothing unless it's
in the very last room ah oil but still
no lantern that does not help me damn it
yeah ok tinder box is the only room
that's actually had something in it
Bible was on the bed why why I have this
Lantern Eva was knotted these ropes
why didn't even go in the frickin play
oh don't you start that [ __ ] with me
don't you start that with me I'll Jack
some [ __ ] I ain't Mazdas comes my way
that's new music and it's not wait my
eyes were adjusting and then they
stopped anything under there that I need
would you start that with me young man I
am not in the mood he'll be dicks around
with like that that's a good scream by
the way oh I couldn't tell if it was a
cry for help or constipation yeah yeah
absolutey hi what that's weird I guess
estranged was it did hello who's up here
oh it's you i under naked okay there's
my lantern one second gotta make sure
sanity parshas did you just die er and
why are you so naked God you show naked
[Music]
No
[Music]
it's a hotel not a castle lantern
contains a few drops of oil hopefully
yes they supply me with plenty of oil
good bat this douche couldn't keep
control of his liquor and he spilled it
all over the place damn wait what
there's some footsteps lalit out what is
this Chester by the by is that supposed
to be Chester did he meet his demise
right here I'm thinking that he might
have why did he get naked then God
everybody is so naked finally have
Lantern yes yes no thank you
I don't want any please go away I would
rather not don't thank you no thank you
no thank you I don't want any go away go
hey that is not cool bruh
not cool bro Edwin's ah Eva what the
hell was that
that was a new monster I don't want to
get out I want to get out of here you
little ooh good god I must follow her
Ava what are you doing oh no no no man
no no Jesus okay what's with the voices
oh man
shut up go away go away boys I'm
supposed to go in here because I was
supposed to go down here oh man Jesus
this is like the most atmospheric that
amnesia has ever been get out my way get
out of my way get out of my way out of
my way
wine-cellar do I have that thank you God
what was this other key that again
chambers I don't know what that is all
about Oh know what that's about I think
something is hunting me now no [ __ ]
[Laughter]
thank you for shutting up and it's quiet
again I'm not sure which I hate more the
quiet whatever the hell that was
okay all right they're just footsteps
I've heard them before Indonesia 15
barrels of ale and 100 bottles of
quality wine all this for Tom and Tom
smoke Wow such a waste
god I hate Midsummer Festival but it's
not my money
I bet the hotel tries to get more
customers this way every year people
start missing during the festival the
hotel manager says it's just a
coincidence but I think there's more to
it I believe it has something to do with
the castles dark history
okay well I'm dumb it's a castle that
was turned into a hotel okay that makes
a lot more sense I should have realized
that a long time ago all right oh man
why would he good God oh it's just a
statue just a statue
this game is messing with my mind like a
lot Explorer abet try to find something
of value before we continue on haha this
game is making very good use of the
statues I don't like it but I appreciate
it know anything here nothing hello mr.
rat run run little rats scamper scamper
away all right this is chair storage
here Oh a button
well that started a little something or
other
some I'm here that I need done look like
it I'm gonna run out of oil
what hi oh so strong
god I'm so great okay anything over here
no I'm just gonna scream randomly locked
look there must be a key for this door
somewhere maybe this key up wrong key
okay so I need to find another key
somewhere in here I'm wasting a lot of
oil but I'd rather not turn it off at
this point in time and I know that
choice is gonna be taken from me this is
the key in question
it must be hello this is it thank you
for being very clear I pushed the button
I'm real good at pushing buttons I lift
things up and put them down I like to
lift things up and put them down yeah
okay so let's just see what's in here
and then what was that Eva pretty tall
for a six-year-old or five-year-old what
the hell go follow her which is it not a
good idea not a good idea hide in the
closet I didn't move your ass hide
how my voice hurt I think I just
sprained something I don't think I've
ever gone that high before in my life
please go away
no thank you I don't want any go away
all righty but girls yeah cookie okay
all right he's gonna go away maybe
unless he burst down the door I have yet
to see a monster actually bust down the
door of a closet you'd think that would
be something that a game maker would
eventually put in just to troll with
people okay so he's gone away thankfully
thank you boxes proving to be excellent
defense like that get to light up in
here if it couldn't have gone this way
there's nothing here
okay so anyway stand in the light okay
all right so I am all out of time for
now thank you all so much for watching
click the annotations for more videos in
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video is he coming back
[Music]
okay
[Music]